nueva esperanza en la lucha por
controlar la pandemia pzifer anunció los
resultados sobre la efectividad de una
nueva pastilla antiviral contra el
coronavirus bajo el nombre de pax lobby
nos enorgullece anunciar que según
nuevos datos nuestro candidato antiviral
oral contra el kobe 19 demostró reducir
significativamente el riesgo de muerte u
hospitalización en adultos de alto
riesgo según fischer el fármaco está
diseñado para bloquear una enzima que el
coronavirus necesita para hacer copias
de sí mismo de este modo se evita que
invada al infectado con esta tecnología
se conseguiría una reducción del 89% en
la tasa de hospitalización y muertes de
pacientes infectados por kobe 19
la altísima eficacia nos sorprende
incluso a nosotros supera las
expectativas más visionarias que
teníamos al respecto ahora nos
lanzaremos de inmediato a ver qué más
podemos hacer en la fabricación de
suministro en el estudio participaron
mil 219 personas de ellos
775 tomaron la píldora la farmacéutica
estima que podría producir 180 paquetes
del fármaco para finales de este año la
cifra ascendería a 50 millones en 2022
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden se pronunció sobre la noticia
ya hemos asegurado millones de dosis y
la terapia sería una herramienta más
para proteger a la gente de los peores
resultados del cob y ambos anuncios
llegan un día después de que reinó
unido- aprobara el uso de una píldora
similar desarrollada por la farmacéutica
merck sin embargo este fármaco destinado
principalmente a personas con factores
de riesgo presenta solamente una
efectividad del 50 por ciento